So let's talk about how to actually
create a surface with the Android STK.
So, as we said, a surface is essentially
a container which casts a shadow.
We can identify which views in
our hierarchy are surfaces and
set appropriate backgrounds and
elevation values.
So let's start with a simple example and
create a screen that contains
a single surface that casts a shadow.
So here I am in Android Studio looking
at a simple activity layout file.
I have a frame layout
which will be our surface.
I can give it a height and
width and some margins and
set its background here to white.
To create a surface, the key thing is
I can set this elevation value here.
Here I'm setting 4dp, and Android
will render that as a shadow for us.
The elevation is the distance of
surfaces above the back plane.
Higher values produce larger shadows.
So here we are running this on a device.
And as you can see,
our frame layout is casting a shadow
along the bottom edge onto
the background behind.
This clearly shows that
it's a separate surface.
Back in Android Studio, I can duplicate
our surface a couple of times,
so the same frame layout.
But here, I'm setting different
values for the elevation.
So we have one set with 4 dp,
a second set is at 8 dp,
and a third at 16 dp in
front of the back plane.
Running this,
we see that Android renders these three
different surfaces of different shadows.
So here's a subtle shadow, a little more
noticeable, and more noticeable still.
The higher the elevation values produce
a larger more diffuse shadow giving
the appearance of being higher up or
further in front of the back plane.